Johnson's popularity is often talked
about in the same breath as escapism
so is this absolutely the perfect time
for this film to come out yeah I think
yeah I hope so I have to say when I saw
it for the first time and then that
music starts and then the lights go down
I just my shoulders went down I thought
this is great just to escape for a
couple of hours or more the nonsense
that we're surrounded by that's a
stressful world we're living in at the
moment and nothing seems nothing gives
anybody confidence anymore I don't think
when you read the paper but there's
something about Downton Abbey that is
reassuring everybody knows their place
everybody knows what their role is and
what the rules are and it's it's sorry
now in the energy is we're lacking as
well of surety and I'm the only B word
you'll hear is Branson yeah and it's
kind of funny to think like the stresses
that they had back there I'm not saying
it was kind of an easier easier living
back then certainly but would it be nice
to kind of almost be transported back
and have a different set of stresses
what do you think we're out there today
as well there's a lot easier but stress
levels must be mmm no I think we all are
very aware of the fact that we're
painting an idealized picture of that
time and I always like to emphasize that
because it's not a documentary I mean
life of the servants in that era was
very very difficult and and for a woman
to like the character I play she
literally had no say over her own
destiny whatsoever and I would not for
one second want to be transported
backwards in time welcome to Downton
Abbey so it feels like journalists like
myself have been hustling you guys for a
long time now about when's this thing
gonna happen when's this thing gonna
happen and when you got the call to say
yes it's gonna happen did you have any
concerns about what it was going to be
like and he kind of worries about the
script or how things would continue or
anything like that
well the gestation period was quite long
I mean I think Gareth first started
talking about it our producer started
talking about it and I first had a whiff
of in season when we were filming season
5 so it's an
then by the time we finished the end of
the series ever certainly talked about
it but I think I think the real question
mark was going to be the logistics of it
trying to get us all back together then
jugen did a couple of iterations of a
script and you know changed the story a
bit and so it did take a while for it to
get there and I if anything if there
wasn't a doubt it was just the doubt of
will we be able to with our producers
manage to get us all in the same arena
room at the same time the king and queen
are coming to town to what at that kind
of level of love from the fans does it
surprise you still just how how much
people love Downton how obsessed with it
people get it it's astonishing it spits
some borderline cultish in some respects
I did a concert at Highclere Castle the
music of Downton Abbey
there was a meet-and-greet with 40
couples before handed paid maybe some
extra money and 60 the 30 of those
couples had flown from America
especially for the concert you know I
mean from the west coast from Kansas
from Texas from all over the states for
a two-hour concert and that is that's
unusual
and the Spanish lady presented me with
them credibly heavy box with 30 pebbles
in it and she painted all of our
characters and I brought it with me
yesterday to try and see if you could
guess which is your character because
some of them look quite similar
humans creatures of habit and we love
kind of being in groups did you
instinctively when the cameras aren't
rolling do you instinctively stay kind
of upstairs downstairs or geographically
it's inevitable because you know that
the kitchens are in a studio and not a
tightly a castle and so we very really
got their new very really yeah very yeah
exactly we don't cross-pollinate
in that sense but but Jim you know Jim
Jim tabbles but up and down the m4
between us the short straw yeah there's
a very different atmosphere is much more
rambunctious
that downstairs just because of the
physical the physical nature of the
studio whereas upstairs is more formal
is quieter so you can't sit and certain
things for people to go out and stretch
their legs on the lawns and stuff like
that so we are shooting in a in a home
with priceless antiques and wallpaper
and and that permeates the atmosphere to
a certain extent you have to be always
very careful of yeah where you're
sitting and the scenes are more static
upstairs you're sitting around a table
whereas we're hustling and bustling more
downstairs and that in fact affects the
the social sort of atmosphere I think
you make more noise dance theater yes
really because we can
when you have enough cliches to get you
through the visit if not I'll come to
you here we go
[Music]
you